waiting through the jungle water teeming
with God knows what in the pitch-black
is starting to seem a very bad idea
any station then before we get our first
sniff of frog something catches my eye a
snakeskin no no no poor bro Jeff Cobras
in here yes with snakes that big
swimming around I'm beginning to get the
heebie-jeebies and I want to turn back
but I've gotta front this out this is
insane
waiting waiting through water for my
supper these frogs better be worth it
then hiding in the undergrowth we spot
our first frog great shot and that's a
good size
that's a good size rock yes
[Music]
I'm amazed by the skill of these guys
once they get their eye in a fresh frog
tally soon mounts
[Music]
with the hard work over mrs. Furr
Valerie is going to show me her famous
stuffed frog recipe I can't wait but you
know the stuff wanting me yeah that's
good size first the probes are killed
gutted and skinned has seen better days
their legs are removed the meat cut off
and finely chopped their misses her
Valerie mixes it with pork mince
so obviously the pork and the fact keeps
it moist it stops the frog from drying
out right yes
next she gets me to make a special
version of corona the classic cambodian
spice paste using fresh turmeric and
kaffir lime garlic and chili then she
mixes the quran with the minced meat
finally for salty death a tablespoon of
fish sauce is an extraordinary aromatic
filling
then I get to stuff my first frog so
you're filling up natural body
she said you seem to know the way to do
it that's very good
using a nifty trick with split bamboo
the frogs are ready for grilling amazing
they look like quails they cook for 15
minutes over low charcoal heat then
they're ready
Shafi with those beautiful words got
round mrs. oven re is cooking a famous
frog recipe good evening so we've got
full house for dinner I'm starting to
see why the revival of traditional
cuisine is so important this old recipe
is fantastic aunty how was it